Americans have enjoyed the tradition of drinking coffee for a relatively short time,...
...but they managed to establish the most famous coffee house chain...
...and make it to one of the most expensive brands in the world.
Is this just for the sake of money and power?
No, it's a question of imagination and crystal - clear principles.
The core of Starbucks philosophy...
...is expressed by CEO Howard Schultz,...
..."We are not in the coffee business, serving people."
"We are in the people business, serving coffee."
Every sales clerk in every Starbucks branch in the world...
...has internalized the basic five principles: be welcoming,...
...authentic, caring, knowledgeable and dedicated.
There are many reasons for the company's success,...
...from their holistic approach of their mission statement to the quality of their coffee,...
...to their environmentally friendly corporate social responsibility statement.
Their marketing strategy is unconventional and stimulating.
And if this innovative company comes up with a new campaign,...
...other companies should take notes.